es ist mehr als angemessen dass wir
heute morgen dem Verstorbenen letzten
Staatspräsidenten der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion und Generalsekretär der
KPdSU gedacht haben
wir verdanken Helmut Kohl
George Bush und eben auch Michael
Gorbatschow die Chance dass unser Land
vor über 30 Jahren die Wiedervereinigung
in Frieden und Freiheit erreichen konnte
hätte Gorbatschow seinen politischen Weg
weitergehen können
wären Glasnost und Perestroika die
prägenden Elemente der russischen
Politik
nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion geblieben
dann wäre nicht nur die russische
Geschichte anders verlaufen die gesamte
europäische Geschichte wäre anders
verlaufen
aber spätestens seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine sind wir
auf schreckliche Weise mit einer ganz
anderen Realität konfrontiert und diese
Realität hat Folgen für ganz Europa aber
auch und ganz besonders für Deutschland
wir haben seit ihrer Regierungserklärung
Herr Bundeskanzler am 27 februar über
diese Folgen oft und intensiv diskutiert
wir haben gemeinsame Entscheidungen
getroffen bis hin zu einer Änderung des
Grundgesetzes und einer gemeinsamen
Entschließung des Deutschen Bundestages
am 28 April über umfassende humanitäre
finanzielle und militärische
mit diesen beiden Entscheidungen enden
dann aber auch
die Gemeinsamkeiten zwischen ihrer
Regierung und uns
sobald der Bundeshaushalt betroffen ist
über den wir in dieser Woche in erster
Lesung beraten
halten sie ihre eigene Zusage nicht ein
der Bundeskanzler der Bundeswehr Zitat
sie erinnern sich möglicherweise
ab sofort jedes Jahr ab sofort jedes
Jahr mehr als zwei Prozent des BIP für
Investitionen in die bündnis- und
Verteidigungsfähigkeit zur Verfügung zu
stellen
der Bundeswehr Etat hätte neben den 100
Milliarden Euro die wir zusammen
beschlossen haben ja für Jahr ansteigen
müssen
stattdessen kürzen Sie von diesem Jahr
auf das nächste Jahr den Etat um 300
Millionen Euro Herr Bundeskanzler wir
müssen es leider feststellen wir können
den von Ihnen gegebenen Zusagen nicht
vertrauen
neben den rein finanziellen Fragen der
Ausstattung der Bundeswehr kommen sie
und ihre Regierung auch der eindeutigen
Aufforderung des Deutschen Bundestages
vom 28 April nicht nach die Ukraine in
ausreichendem Maße mit schweren Waffen
zu versorgen und fällt niemandem von uns
leicht zu verstehen dass der Einsatz von
Waffen den Frieden näher bringen kann
aber lassen Sie mich vielleicht zitieren
aus einem Interview lassen Sie mich
zitieren aus einem Interview dass einer
der renommiertesten national- und
international anerkannten
Politikwissenschaftler unseres Landes
vor zwei Wochen in der Berliner Zeitung
gegeben hat das ist Herr Fried Münkler
er sagt ich bin erstaunt über die
Naivität eines Teils der intellektuellen
Szene und mancher Politiker in
Deutschland die offenbar glauben dass
Putin an den Verhandlungstisch kommen
wird wenn man ihn dazu auffordert
das Gegenteil ist der Fall Russland so
sagt er muss durch militärische
Misserfolge zu Gesprächen mit der
Ukraine gezwungen werden mit
Waffenlieferungen aus dem Ausland
beschleunigt man also einen Prozess an
dessen Ende Verhandlungen stehen
in Deutschland gibt es offenbar keine
Kultur des militärischen strategischen
Denkens deswegen werden diese aus
Expertensicht absurden Forderungen nicht
als falsch erkannt der Weg so schließt
er an den Verhandlungstisch führt einzig
über militärische Erfolge der Ukraine
die Russland die Aussicht auf den großen
Sieg nehmen Ende des Zitats der
Bundeskanzler
Herr Bundeskanzler
diese klaren Worte diese klaren Worte
hätten wir einmal von ihnen erwartet
damit hätten sie nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern damit hätten sie für
ganz Europa ein bisschen politische
Führung übernommen
nimmt man
die Worte von Herfried Münkler ernst und
wir tun das dann ist die Zögerlichkeit
der Ukraine noch intensiver zu helfen
einen Grund dafür dass dieser Krieg sich
verlängert erfordert noch mehr Opfer auf
beiden Seiten als dieser Krieg ohnehin
schon gefordert hat
die Länge dieses Krieges verschärft auch
die wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland
und in Europa wir müssen heute meine
Damen und Herren davon ausgehen dass vor
allem Deutschland aufgrund seiner ich
sage ausdrücklich nicht von dieser
Regierung allein zu verantwortenden
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland in
besonderen Maße von diesem drohenden
Versorgungsengpässen
ich habe es doch gerade gesagt
ausdrücklich nicht von ihnen allein zu
verantworten wird Abhängigkeit von
russischen Gas in besonderer Weise
betroffen
jenseits aller Details
meine Damen und Herren jenseits aller
Details und ich werde auf zwei zu
sprechen kommen fehlt ihnen und ihre
Regierung aber auch in
wirtschaftspolitischer Hinsicht jeder
Kompass ja man muss es leider so sagen
auch in der Wirtschaftspolitik fehlt
dieser Bundesregierung jede Fähigkeit
zum politischen strategischen Denken
sie mögen
sie Mühen und streiten sich über Wochen
und Monate die gesamte Sommerpause ist
doch bestimmt gewesen von einem
permanenten Streit dieser Koalition über
Wochen und herausgekommen ist wieder
einmal ein Sammelsurium und ein
Kompromissen auf dem Niveau des
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenners den diese
Koalition noch zusammenhält weit davon
entfernt weit davon entfernt
sachgerechte Antworten auf diese
gewaltigen Herausforderungen zu gehen
vor denen wir stehen und lassen Sie mich
meine Damen und Herren beginnen mit
einer rein formalen Frage der Frage der
Zuständigkeiten spätestens diese Krise
und das Durcheinander in ihrer Koalition
hätten Sie Herr Bundeskanzler zum Anlass
nehmen müssen im Bundeskanzleramt einen
energiesicherheitsrat noch besser einen
Nationalen Sicherheitsrat aus
Mitgliedern der Bundesregierung und
Experten von außen einzurichten
spätestens diese Krise wäre Veranlassung
gewesen die Zuständigkeit an sich zu
ziehen wenn sie können die hochkomplexen
Fragen der Energiepolitik und der
Versorgungssicherheit unseres Landes in
einer solchen existenziellen Krise doch
nicht allen Ernstes einem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann den wir immer wieder
beim Denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist der aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner Partei und in
seinem Apparat von einer Gruppe aus
Lobbyisten der Umweltpolitik die alles
zur Strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aus sich auf Erfolg hat
diese Krise in den Griff zu bekommen
und mit Verlauf wie hilflos Herr Habeck
sie in diesen Fragen sind das konnte man
gestern Abend im deutschen Fernsehen
beobachten man kann nur hoffen man kann
nur hoffen
dass ein Großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen Unternehmer und vor
allem der Bäckerinnen und Bäcker um
diese Uhrzeit schon im Bett gelegen
haben und geschlafen haben und das nicht
mit ansehen mussten was sie da gestern
Abend von sich gegeben haben man kann es
nur hoffen
das größte Problem
das große Problem vor dem wir heute
stehen meine Damen und Herren ist die
hohe Geldentwertung die jahrelange
notdienstpolitik der EZB hat den Sparern
in Deutschland erst die
renditenvorenthalten und jetzt geht es
an die Substanz und noch weitreichender
sind die Folgen noch weitreichender sind
die Folgen für unsere gesamte
Volkswirtschaft viele Unternehmen ja wir
sind diese Zwischenrufe meine Damen und
Herren zeigen nur dass sie ganz
offensichtlich keine Ahnung von dem
haben was in den privaten Haushalten und
in den Unternehmen im Augenblick in
Deutschland los ist sie haben
offensichtlich keine Ahnung ich gebe
Ihnen mal ein Beispiel
viele Unternehmen viele Unternehmen in
Deutschland haben die Auftragsbücher im
Augenblick so voll wie schon seit Jahren
nicht mehr aber sie können diese
Aufträge nicht abarbeiten sie geben sie
zurück weil die Lieferketten
unterbrochen sind weil die Preise durch
die Decke gehen und weil sie nicht mehr
in der Lage sind die Aufträge
abzuarbeiten die sie schon seit längerer
Zeit in den Büchern stehen haben das hat
etwas mit der Inflationsrate und der
geltentwertung und den Lieferketten zu
tun schauen Sie sich das doch bitte in
ihren Wahlkreisen einmal an jeder von
uns bekommt jeden Tag Nachrichten und
Briefe aus den Unternehmen die genau auf
diesen Sachverhalt hinweisen und sie
gehen mit einer bemerkenswerten Ignoranz
über dieses Thema hinweg und reden nur
über Hilfsprogramme statt einmal das
Thema wirklich an der Wurzel zu packen
sucht man sucht man in ihrem Papier von
vergangenen Sonntag nach Lösungen zu
diesem Problem stößt man vor allem
gratulation an die FDP dass sie die
kalte Progression abbauen wollen meine
Damen und Herren da steht im Gesetz dass
sie das ohnehin machen müssen und sie
sind dazu verpflichtet diese Frage alle
zwei Jahre zu klären und es gibt doch
zumindest eine moralische Verpflichtung
das jetzt zu tun und nicht erst im Jahr
2023 sondern jetzt im Jahr 2022 wäre die
richtige Antwort im Jahr der Krise
gewesen diese Entscheidung zu treffen
stattdessen stattdessen halten sie fest
stattdessen halten sie fest an der
gasumlage die zum 1 Oktober nun in Kraft
treten sollen diese gasumlage wird die
Inflationsrate in Deutschland noch
weiter in die Höhe treiben sie wird die
privaten Haushalte noch höher belasten
und sie wird vor allen Dingen die
Unternehmen in Deutschland zu einem
Zeitpunkt wo sie es nun überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen können mit tausenden
Hunderttausenden Millionen zusätzlicher
Kosten belasten nur weil sie in dieser
Bundesregierung krampfhaft an dieser
Umlage festhalten die von Anfang an eine
Fehlkonstruktion gewesen ist und sie
nicht die Kraft haben das jetzt hier zu
korrigieren es wäre richtig gewesen
es wäre richtig gewesen diese Umlage
aufzuheben sie können das übrigens mit
uns zusammen in dieser Woche tun der
entsprechende Antrag der liegt im
Deutschen Bundestag vor und stattdessen
die relevanten Unternehmen die Gas
Import Importeure unter einen
staatlichen Schutzschirm zu stellen so
wie wir das mit den Banken in der
Finanzkrise und mit einigen Unternehmen
wegen der während der corona-krise
einmal gemacht haben die System die
Systematik die Instrumente sind
vorhanden sie weigern sich auf diese
Instrumente zurückgreifen weil sie im
Kopf durch die Wand wollen und eine
einmal geschlossene Entscheidung nicht
zurücknehmen wollen das ist die Wahrheit
mit dieser Gasanlage und nun
nun kommt
nun kommt das Meisterstück dieser
Regierung nämlich die Entscheidung vom
Montag dieser Woche über den
Atomausstieg ich meine Damen und Herren
zunächst einmal vor der Klammer damit
das klar ist natürlich muss man den
Menschen in einer solchen Situation
helfen wenn die Energiepreise steigen
wenn die privaten Haushalte hoch
belastet sind muss man helfen und sie
haben durchaus in dem Papier von
vergangenen Sonntag einige richtige
Beschlüsse gefasst ich nenne Ihnen mal
nur zwei an der Zahlen also sie
beschweren sich doch darüber dass wir zu
viel kritisieren jetzt sage ich mal
etwas vielleicht sage ich Ihnen mal
etwas wo sie richtig liegen sie haben
Gott sei Dank gesehen dass sie die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und die
Studierenden in Deutschland übersehen
haben bei dem letzten Hilfspaket und
korrigieren das jetzt aber Herr
Bundeskanzler jetzt mal ganz im Ernst
300 Euro für jeden Haushalt sie und ich
bekommen das in diesen Tagen auch
überwiesen
brauchen sie das
brauchen wir das oder gibt es vielleicht
in diesem Land Haushalte mit einem
Durchschnittseinkommen von vielleicht
1.500 1600 Euro im Monat netto die eher
1000 Euro gebraucht hätten statt alle
300 es wäre besser gewesen dass auch
diejenigen zu konzentrieren die es
wirklich brauchen statt mit der
Gießkanne durchs Land zu gehen und jedem
Haushalt ein solchen Betrag zu
überweisen ich will eine zweite ich will
eine zweite Entscheidung nennen die in
der Presseberichterstattung wie ich
finde bedauerlicherweise etwas zu sehr
in den Hintergrund getreten ist die
Entscheidung den Tarifvertragsparteien
das Angebot zu machen ein Einmalbetrag
von 3.000 Euro zu verabreden der dann
Steuer- und abgabenfrei ist ist richtig
und ich will von dieser Stelle auch den
Tarifvertragsparteien sagen nehmen Sie
dieses Angebot in Anspruch damit sie
jetzt möglichst schnell den privaten
Haushalt mit einer solchen Einmalzahlung
helfen das ist eine richtige
Entscheidung dieser Bundesregierung
aber meine Damen und Herren das sind
doch alles das sind doch alles
Reparaturen an einem Problem dass sie in
der Wurzel nicht anfassen wir haben es
mit dieser Gaspreisentwicklung mit einem
klassischen
angebotsschock zu tun was macht man wenn
man einen solchen angebotsschock erlebt
dann versucht man doch zunächst einmal
darauf zu reagieren indem man alle
Möglichkeiten nutzt das vorhandene
Angebot das immer noch zur Verfügung
steht auszuschöpfen und zwar mit ganzer
Kraft und jede Möglichkeit zu nutzen
das nennt man meine Damen und Herren das
nennt man Marktwirtschaft der ein oder
andere wird diesen Begriff von ihnen
schon mal gehört haben so reagiert man
in einer Marktwirtschaft auf einen
angebotsschock und diese Reaktion wäre
richtig gewesen im Hinblick auf die
gesamte Palette der Energieversorgung
die wir in diesem Lande haben
stattdessen wird in dieser Regierung
weiter verzögert herumlaviert verhindert
und wertvolle Zeit vergeudet ich nenne
Ihnen den Beispiele da sind die
Steinkohlekraftwerke den sie erst die
Betriebserlaubnis geben wieder
hochzufahren wenn für mehrere Wochen die
Reserven auf dem Hof liegen das gilt für
die Biomasse wir haben hier darüber
gesprochen sie wollten den Deckel
Aufheben der ist bis heute bei 1000 MW
gedeckelt es nach wie vor vorhanden aus
Biomasse könnte das Zehnfache an Strom
gewonnen werden was wir heute unter
diesem Deckel liegen haben
das gilt für die
Braunkohlekraftwerke von denen immer
noch einige Blöcke stillstehen und das
Ergebnis ist dass wir im Jahr 2022 mehr
Gas verstromt haben als in vielen Jahren
vorher wir sind in einem Land in einer
Zeit in der Gas gespart werden muss
gespeichert werden muss und durch ihre
Blockadehaltung gegenüber anderen Formen
der Stromerzeugung fahren wir in
Deutschland die Gaskraftwerke hoch und
erzeugen Strom obwohl es andere
Möglichkeiten gäbe diesen Strom zu
erzeugen und dann und dann diese
Entscheidung
dann diese Entscheidung meine Damen und
Herren zu erkennenergie was sie da am
Montag verkündet haben er Habeck jetzt
hat das Parlament schon verlassen
wahrscheinlich guckt er sich gerade mal
die Filme von gestern Abend an
aber meine Damen und Herren was da am
Montagabend was da am Montagabend
verkündet worden ist
das beruhigt möglicherweise die grüne
Basis vor allem in Niedersachsen in
Wahrheit halten Sie mit dieser Politik
das ganze Land zum Narren und
beschädigen möglicherweise
unwiderruflich die deutschen Unternehmen
den gesamten Wirtschaftsstandort und vor
allem die mittelständischen Unternehmen
in unserem Land
damit
meine Damen und Herren damit das
von dieser Stelle aus klar wird weil die
das hin und wieder auch anders in
Deutschland verbreiten niemand von uns
will zurück zur alten Kernenergie
[Applaus]
also vielleicht muss ich für Sie
vielleicht muss ich es für sie noch mal
wiederholen damit sie es verstehen
niemand von uns will zurück zur alten
Kernenergie die wir 2011 in Deutschland
beendet haben aber in einer
die ganze die ganze
Ignoranz zu diesem Thema die steht ihnen
ins Gesicht geschrieben wenn man von
dieser Stelle aus wenn man von dieser
Stelle ausspricht
meine Damen und Herren wir haben wir
haben in Deutschland wir haben in
Deutschland noch drei laufende
Kernkraftwerke das sind die modernsten
und sichersten Kernkraftwerke der Welt
die ganze Welt drumherum schaut auf
Deutschland und draußen sagen die Leute
sind diese Deutschen eigentlich verrückt
geworden in einer solchen Situation drei
Kernkraftwerke stillzulegen die in der
Lage wären zehn Millionen Haushalte
sicher mit Strom zu versorgen
meine Damen und Herren das ist doch das
ist das hat doch ein Niveau an
Irrationalität erreicht das kann man
doch gar nicht mehr beschreiben wir
haben Ihnen das Angebot gemacht in den
Sommerferien eine Sondersitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages durchzuführen mit
einer Änderung des Atomgesetzes die
hätten mit Ihnen gemeinsam den Weg
gegangen dies für drei oder vier Jahre
zu ermöglichen nicht mehr aber bitte
auch nicht weniger aber das was sie
jetzt da machen ist doch ein fauler
Kompromiss die beiden Atomkraftwerke die
nach ihrem Willen im Standby-Betrieb
bleiben sollen und alle Fachleute sagen
Ihnen dass das hochgradiger Unfug ist
das zu machen müssen die komplette
Mannschaft vorhalten bleiben am Netz
sollen hochgefahren werden wenn wir ein
Problem in Deutschland haben ich sage
Ihnen wir werden nicht nur ein Problem
haben sie haben vor einigen Wochen mal
gesagt wir hätten keinen Stromproblem
wir hätten ein gasproblem wir sind
mittendrin in einem massiven
Stromproblem in diesem Land und sie
haben es offensichtlich bis heute
verstanden das ist so ist
so und wenn sie wenn sie dafür sorgen
wollen dass die Preise runtergehen in
Deutschland dass die Hilfsmaßnahmen die
wir gemeinsam vielleicht ergreifen
müssen nicht über Borden und den
Haushalt überstrapazieren dann muss man
auf der Angebotsseite alles tun damit
genug Strom damit genug Energie in
diesem Lande verfügbar ist und das ist
keine Frage der Netzstabilität die ja
sie haben prüfen lassen das ist eine
Frage der
Stromerzeugungskapazitäten in
Deutschland nun regen sich mal nicht auf
die parlamentsärztin ist da wenn Sie
wollen gehen Sie gleich gehen
zu ihnen sagen weil eines zu ihnen sagen
wenn Sie wenn Sie mit Ihrer Fraktion der
Meinung sind diese Probleme die wir
jetzt haben zum Gegenstand von
Auseinandersetzung auf den Straßen in
Deutschland machen zu wollen dann werden
wir Ihnen mit allem was wir haben und
notfalls mit
allen an dass sie dieses Land mit ihrer
Politik de stabilisieren das werden wir
nicht zulassen und das machen wir dann
notfalls mit allen anderen zusammen um
zu verhindern dass sie da ihr braunes
dunkle Püppchen kochen
nein meine Damen und Herren Herr
Bundeskanzler
ich will es Ihnen ausdrücklich sagen für
auch Zeit muss diese Kapazität am Netz
bleiben damit senken wir die Preise
damit senken wir die Kosten für die
Unternehmen damit schaffen wir
Planungssicherheit auch für die
Unternehmen in Deutschland und ich will
sie aufrufen die Lage spitzt sich in den
nächsten Tagen Wochen und Monaten
möglicherweise dramatisch zu und sie
wissen es sie haben die Gesprächspartner
die ihnen das gesagt haben und es dürfte
alles andere als eine Übertreibung sein
ich sage Ihnen der Bundeskanzler stoppen
Sie diesen Irrsinn aus ihrer Koalition
solange wir die Zeit dafür noch haben
herzlichen Dank